PRESENTER 1: It randomly
chooses a number
and flashes five times.
And if it chooses a
number between 1 to 5,
you have a chance
to win a lottery.
We have lotteries here.
By the way, there's
[? 50 ?] percent
of chances that you
get punched in the face
or like a punishment, right?
PRESENTER 2: Yeah, some
sort of punishment.
PRESENTER 1: Yeah, some
And we welcome all
of you to try it.
PRESENTER 2: Mine is--
I named it an Imprecise
Ardruino Ruler.
So this is like an
ultrasonic sensor
in that it can tell distance.
So I set it up with
a series of lights.
So we'll just have this
piece of cardboard.
If you have just a piece
of cardboard over here,
it shows that it's
five centimeters away.
If you move it farther
away, more like [INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER 1: So eventually, we
want to combine them together,
like how many lights
show on there,
they would display
the number over here.
And then win the lottery.
But since they're on two
different ardruino boards
we just make it separate and
play with the LEDs right now.
So what I would
suggest right now,
if somebody is going to receive
either punishment or reward,
they get close to the
sensor and get the reward
from Franklin over there.
So we have to be careful.
OK,
AUDIENCE: So I say, like, two.
So right, I just
guess the number two.
PRESENTER 1: Yeah, you
don't have to guess it,
it will randomly choose it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PRESENTER 1: So you're
completely relying on God.
PRESENTER 2: It
slowly lights up.
AUDIENCE: What's the
percentage on it?
PRESENTER 2: It's
very imprecise.
This lights up from distance
from five to 10 centimeters.
This lights up when
the object is 10 to 15,
this is 15 to 20 and so on.